[موسيقى]
اعلنت الولايات المتحده تزويد اوكرانيا
بذخائر عنقوديه لاول مره منذ بدء الحرب
كنداك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما الذي دفع واشنطن لتزويد كياب
ببخائر عنقوديه لاول مره منذ بدء الحرب
وكيف ستتعامل موسكو مع هذا التطور وما هي
المتغيرات التي يمكن ان يفرضها على
استراتيجيتها وما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله
لهذا التصيد على فرص التسويه بالنظر
للحراك التركي
[موسيقى]
تواصل الولايات المتحده دعمها المستمر
لاوكرانيا باعلانها اليوم عن حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه جديده
في مرحله تحاول ان تخترق فيها الدفاعات
الروسيه لاستعاده اراضيها هذه الذخيره
ستكون مفيده جدا وهذا ياتي في وقت
انظمه هاي مارس
ليس فيها ما يكفي من الذخائر ايضا
لذلك هذا النوع من الذخائر هو مهم جدا
تقدم خدمه اضافيه ونوعيه للجانب الاوكراني
في الفتره الحاليه لماذا لانها الهجوم
المضاد تباطا لم يحقق اهداف المقرره بسبب
شبكه التحصينات وهذا قرار من واشنطن لماذا
لانهم قد استنفذوا جميع
الذخيره التي تستخدم للمدفعيه العاديه
المستودعات في فرنسا والمانيا وبريطانيا
وفي حتى مستودعات امريكا ان الذخيره هناك
قد استنفذت ولقد خسروا كل الصواريخ
والذيره
175 ملم
هذه القنابل اول من استخدمها
1943 للاتحاد السوفيتي ضد القوات النازيه
الالمانيه واستخدمتها المانيا وتحديدا في
افغانستان استخدمتها امريكا واستخدمت
روسيا في ناغورنو كارباخ استخدمتها
ارمينيا واذربيجان استخدمتها اسرائيل في
1982 وال 2006 واستقدم من قبل ثمانيه
وعشرين دوله في الحروب السابقه خلال
العقود الماضيه
هي اسلحه دمار شامل
وهذه تقريبا ربع الصاروخ النووي التكتيكي
وهذا بالنسبه لنا يعني انه في لحظه من
اللحظات واشنطن سوف تقوم بتقديم
لاوكرانيا اسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه وسوف تبدا
حرب نوويه وعندها سوف تضطر روسيا للرد على
استخدام هذه الاسلحه روسيا تستخدم
الذخائر العنقوديه في اوكرانيا
وليس هذا مماثلا لاستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
وروسيا فقط هددت باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه لا هذا سلاح تقليدي المشكله
تكمن في في طريقه التفجير لانه ثلاث انواع
النوع الاول
توقيتي يتم تفجيره في الجو وينفجر الى
ثلاثمائه شظيه النوع الاخر صادم ينفجر
لحظه الاصطدام ويحتاج الى ارض صلبه النوع
الثالث
بعد الاصطدام يكون الفيوز تاخيري
توصيل هذه الاسلحه العنقوديه لاوكرانيا هو
دليل على ان واشنطن هي قاتله لا معنى
للتفكير في ان اوكرانيا سوف
تقصف مدنيها هي تستخدمها لحمايه مدنيه
وضد القوات الروسيه التي تهاجم اوكرانيا
لان المحاسبه ليست على نوع المقذوف
المحاسبه على طبيعه الهدف اذا استخدمت ضد
المدنيين تعتبر جريمه حرب اذا استخدمت ضد
مواقع عسكريه تعتبر سلاح تقليدي
تريد التصعيد روسيا تريد ان تتوقف عن
العمليات العسكريه فورا ولكن على الشرط ان
اوكرانيا سوف تكون حياديه وان اله الارهاب
سوف تتغير وان اللغه الروسيه لن تكون
محظوره في اوكرانيا لا اعتقد ان استفزاز
روسيا يحتاج اي
حساباتها تهاجم اوكرانيا وترتكب جرائم حرب
حتى الان لم تستخدم روسيا الاسلحه
العنقوديه ولن تقوم بهذا ولكن اذا ظهرت
هذه الاسلحه على الجبهات سوف نقوم
باستخدام الاسلحه العنقوديه ايضا كرد على
هذا للاسف نقوم بكل شيء حتى لا يكون هناك
تصعيد اكثر من تقرير اثبت ان روسيا منذ
بدايه الحرب استخدمت القنابل العنقوديه
وان اوكرانيا استخدمتها ثلاث مرات بالتالي
كلا الجانبين استخدم القنابل العنقوديه في
هذه الحرب اوكرانيا هي محتله سياسيا من
الولايات المتحده والولايات المتحده هي من
تدير حرب ضد روسيا بايدي اوكرانيه ليست في
حرب ضد روسيا هذه حرب روسيه ضد اوكرانيا
لا ينبغي ان نقلق من استفزاز روسيا ينبغي
ان نهتم بهزيمه روسيا